today on the matt welsh show two black
teens burned a white man to death
and the media all but completely ignored
the story meanwhile an attack on massage
parlors in atlanta is being desperately
linked to white supremacy despite a
total lack of evidence for the
connection
plus five headlines including the state
department battling the scourge of
entrenched whiteness
ron desantis battling the much more
serious scourge of critical race theory
and a gofundme for prince harry and
meghan markle somehow fails to gain
traction i don't know how
in our daily cancellation we'll deal
with an article in the scientific
american which tries to debunk the case
for
banning males from female sports does it
succeed in debunking it we'll find that
out today and so much more on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
this past june a woman named althea
bernstein
claimed that she was set on fire by four
white men while waiting at a stoplight
in the middle of downtown madison
wisconsin
at 1 a.m she said the assailants who
happen to be in standing in the middle
of the street with all the necessary
materials for whatever reason
doused her with lighter fluid and then
threw a lighter into the car
you know like they do in the movies
where they throw a lighter and then
something lights on fire
uh it doesn't really work with most
lighters in real life but that's what
she said and it set her face on fire
somehow she was left only with a few
splotchy burns on one side of her face
after her face being on fire
one would expect a bit more visible
damage from having her whole face
set ablaze one would also expect that
four flame-throwing murderous white guys
attempting to burn people alive in the
middle of the city would attract the
attention of at least a few witnesses
not to mention security cameras but the
alleged men in the alleged attack was
witnessed by no one
and no evidence of the assailants
appeared on any camera anywhere in the
city
there was also no trace of burn marks or
accelerant in the vehicle she was
driving
when she was supposedly set on fire so
police investigated the hate crime claim
and eventually closed the case because
they could not find a single shred of
evidence to substantiate it
althea's attackers vanished into the
night much like jesse
smallett's attackers and the terrorists
who hung a rope in
bubba wallace's garage it's almost as
though they never existed at all
but despite the fact that this event as
reported by bernstein was almost
certainly a hoax
and had all the hallmarks of a hoax from
the very beginning still it made
headlines and as you'd expect
the races of the victim and her probably
imaginary attackers were front and
center in the headlines
the headlines only disappeared once it
became clear that the story was turning
into an embarrassment for those who
hyped it up to begin with
now i bring this case up now again
because it provides an interesting
contrast considering now the case of
stephen amenhauser 40
53 years old mentally ill now dead
after being brutally murdered last week
two black teenagers
xavion perry and adriel riley jr a
junior
ages 16 and 14 have been charged with
entering his home
and setting him on fire according to
police they watched him burn for a
little bit
before leaving the victim was eventually
found
transported to a hospital where he
succumbed to his burns after a couple of
days
he suffered what is quite literally the
most painful death
possible no motive has been given for
the crime and there's no indication
that hate crime charges are even being
considered at this point
which doesn't mean that there's no
evidence that whether that was a hate
crime just means that they're not
they're not considering
right now calling it that i ask you have
you have you heard about this case i
mean heard about it somewhere besides
from me right now
or one of the other hosts or our website
and if you did hear about it did you
hear about the races of the people
involved
almost certainly not a search on google
turns up a few articles about this crime
which
didn't sound like this happened 10 years
ago it happened just last week
but nothing i mean nothing in any
mainstream outlet mentioning the racial
dichotomy
is that because the media has decided
that race is now irrelevant in violent
crime
well we know that's certainly not the
case all we have to do is look at the
other tragic event of the past week
which happened when a man walked into
massage parlors in atlanta and murdered
eight people
the killer is white six of the victims
were asian
two were white now here it would be hard
to find headlines
that don't mention the races of those
involved and expressly draw a connection
between race and the crime we're told
that this is the result of white
supremacy that the killer was a white
supremacist
one of many out to kill asians
the only problem is that there is no
evidence of that here's a
police spokesman yesterday telling us
what they know about the motive at this
point listen
the suspect did uh take responsibility
for the shootings
um he uh stood that early on once we
began the interviews with him
um he claims that these and as the chief
said we know this is still early but he
does claim that it was not racially
motivated
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a a
fiction and sees these locations as
something that allows him to to um
to go to these places and and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate
um like i said it's still early on but
that was
those were comments that he made did he
discuss any kind of religious
uh motivation for this or was he
responsible not that i'm aware of
nothing more non-political i've heard
nothing about politics
well that's what he says now typically
the person who commits the act is a
pretty good authority on what their
motivation was
also typically if someone is is and we
know this from past events
mass killings and so on attacks that are
racially or ethnically motivated
oftentimes the person who does it for
those reasons is happy to tell you that
that was the reason
so by all accounts it sounds like this
was a lunatic motivated by sexual rage
and jealousy
could still turn out that there was more
to it than that but that's what we know
right now
that would explain why he killed both
asian and white women
the disappointment from the left to the
news that this was not racially
motivated
as far as we know has been palpable for
many of them from what it seems
the tragedy is not that humans died but
that the crime isn't useful to their
narrative
i mean the media is downright excited by
happy about violent crime committed by
white men
i mean they are happy about it they like
it
they can barely contain their glee in
their minds
humans are not anything but props anyway
they have no value none of us have value
to the media outside of our political
usefulness
and that's why there was a mad rush to
declare this crime not only racially
motivated
but part of a trend an epidemic a
pandemic of whiteness as the website the
root put it
sure the facts don't fit with this
narrative but so what facts can be
manipulated ignored invented lied about
as we have seen
as for the real facts it must be noted
that yes there has been a rise
in violent crime against asians but much
of that has come at the hands of
non-white people
a lot of violence against asians is
committed by black men it's just the
fact
anti-asian sentiment has been a problem
in the black community for a long time
and you don't have to take my word for
it it's not just me telling you that the
left-wing media admits this
but of course they put the blame
elsewhere so take this headline from vox
on tuesday
echoing a common talking point that you
see all over social media and the media
right now
um their headline is the history of
tensions and solidarity between black
and asian
asian american communities explained in
the subtitle
how white supremacy tried to divide
black and asian americans
and how communities work to find common
ground
okay so acknowledging these tensions
but these tensions between the two
non-white groups of people are the fault
of
you guessed it white people of course
well that's easy to determine when
everything is the fault of white people
you know i wonder if this is the fault
of white people too in february an
asian woman in milwaukee was tortured
raped beaten
and killed in a park in broad daylight
she was apparently
hanging out in the park laying on a
blanket in the park
and next thing you know she's being
taken tortured raped and beat
two black teenagers were arrested for
that crime now there's another story
that you probably didn't hear about and
if you did hear about it most likely not
what the race is highlighted or
mentioned at all
liz plank an msnbc contributor tweeted
in response to the massage
the massage parlor killings she said
white masculinity fetishizes and
dehumanizes asian women
and it is intrinsically tied to racism
it's crucial that we don't erase the way
that misogyny and racism
operate together to justify killing
asian women now
i haven't checked admittedly but i feel
rather certain and i will eat my words
if i'm wrong
i feel rather certain that she never
said anything about black masculinity
dehumanizing and fetishizing asian women
in response to the rape and murder of
misleading milwaukee
you know the the the media has its
villains and also it's good guys
every story is already written it's only
a matter of
making reality fit into the boxes that
they have set up for it
whatever can't be fit is simply
discarded or denied
as they say when you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail well when
you're the american media
everything looks like white supremacy
and whatever doesn't look like it
doesn't exist now let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
[Music]
you know it could not be more important
than it is right now to support
companies
that have our values and our morals and
uh and support us in the culture
and one company that i'm always telling
you about of course is charity mobile
and i tell you about them because
um i use charity mobile and they really
are a great company they're the pro-life
phone company
because five percent of your monthly
plan price goes to the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice
a lot of other perks on top of that you
get new activations eligible accounts
get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
there's no contract no termination fees
and that means that
they're not getting you locked into
anything you might as well try it out
see if you like the service i think you
will
you're also going to like that they have
live customer service based right here
in the usa
you have the ability to block use of
cellular data picture messages text
messages on any or all of your accounts
so you get that
extra security for your kids especially
and on top of all of that the free apps
to monitor your usage and everything
else
you're also helping to build a culture
of life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company
you can turn everyday living into
effortless giving for the charity of
your choice with charity mobile
what you got to do is call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com
the um the house just passed this
resolution
to give congressional gold medals to
the capitol police for their
courage in the face of the quote
insurrection which is how the resolution
phrases are calling it
an insurrection um and it was it was it
was voted and approved by
almost everyone with the exception of 12
republicans who said that they're not
going to vote for this
and of course now they're being well how
dare you you know the leftists are
are pretending to um to be to be
offended
that these 12 republicans allegedly
aren't supporting the police
how could you not these are the police
back the blue
thomas massey one of the congressmen who
voted against the measure
explained his reasoning and he said one
of the big reasons is that they call
it an insurrection you know we have this
official document calling it
insurrection
while we're in the middle of of criminal
cases
tied to this event and so i don't want
to i don't want to be involved in that
call it something else because that can
be prejudicial call it something else
and and i'll vote for it
that's a very it's a very good reason
not to vote for it
the other reason not to vote for it is
that this is of course we know entire
entirely political
the the capitol police these are the
only police officers
in the country that the democrats have
ever shown any support for
they just now have discovered their
great passion
for um you know protecting law
enforcement and supporting law
enforcement
but only those law enforcement officers
who were there on
that particular day
really with the republicans so it's all
a charade it's all a political charade
obviously
and uh of course most republicans are
too stupid to see that or too cowardly
to do anything about it so they go along
they go right along with it
because they're afraid if they vote
against it that the media is gonna be
mad at us and they're gonna
let me mad at you no matter what you do
it's obviously a political charade the
point
is not to give the medals to the police
officers the point is to call it an
insurrection again
that's entirely political why would you
go along with it knowing that
what i'd like to see the republicans do
if they had any spine
they'd pass a resolution to give
or put together a resolution to give
congressional gold medals to
all the police officers across the
country who defended our cities from blm
terrorists and call them that
in the resolution of course the only
problem is that
in so many cases the police did not
defend the cities from the blm
terrorists but instead
sat back and let it all happen but but
uh even so
all right let's go that wasn't my number
one what's my number one uh here from
the daily wire the department of defense
is
not the only cabinet-level agency
undergoing a woke makeover according to
politico the state department
is also wrestling with its identity and
racing to address a 232-year history of
quote
entrenched whiteness politico reports
that anthony
blinken's state department is racing to
address the 232 year old problem the
overwhelming and entrenched whiteness
of the nation's oldest government agency
the department's 23
000 or so american staff may be the
global face of america but they don't
look like it
and the gap is growing not shrinking by
many metrics
though 40 of the american population is
from a racial or ethnic minority
only 13 of the department's senior
executive services
um are people of color and so this is a
big problem we have to do something
about
you know what i agree it's a big problem
i think that um
all the white people in the state
department should step down in fact i
think that
all of the white people in biden's
government should do the right thing and
step down all including himself
entrenched whiteness is a big big
problem i agree
if you really cared about it these are
white people
again including biden trying to
supposedly address the problem of
entrenched whiteness whatever the hell
that is
seems like you should probably as
michael jackson would say
start with the man in the mirror look at
yourself
i think that's the best thing joe biden
could do he could he could uh
you know hold a press conference today
and rely
and and say listen we've had almost
nothing but white men
as president and um it's too much
and it's wrong and so i'm going to step
down and resign
if he really cared that's what he would
do
of course i say that i would want him to
do that but then we end up with camilla
harris so i'm not sure how much better
that would really be
and we already have really president
camel harris i guess it would be sort of
a lateral move
anyway more diversity news governor
newsom has
in california has pledged to nominate a
black woman to replace
senator feinstein if she retires now it
doesn't like senator feinstein is
retiring
but if she does here's what
newsome says he will do let's watch okay
we are out of time out of time out of
time i have to go to a break but i have
to there's a yes or no answer that you
could give me
uh if in fact dianne feinstein were to
retire
uh will you nominate an african-american
woman
um to restore the seat that kamala
harris is no longer in the united states
senate and do you have a name in mind
i have multiple names in mind
we have multiple names in mind and the
answer is yes
the answer is yes i will this clearly
obviously should be illegal
it should be illegal to declare ahead of
time
what race you're looking for for a
particular job
it is illegal actually at least in the
private sector
um you shouldn't be able to do that
that's that's that's discrimination
you're you're declaring ahead of time
that you're
discriminating against anyone who does
not fall into this
into this uh particular group so that
that should be illegal for to do that
on top of the fact that obviously it's
uh
on top of being discriminatory it's also
infantilizing
the left as we know doesn't care about
this but
there he if he's saying this ahead of
time
and then you are the black woman who
gets nominated for the seat
you know that a big part of the reason
is only because of the color of your
skin and your gender
you know that he said it
i know if it were me i would i'd be kind
of insulted by that i would want to at
least think
that my achievements and my talent
that's the reason i got the position
or nominated for the position but he's
saying ahead of time that's not it we're
not taking that
that's that's not the first thing we're
looking at
so i'm not nominating you i'm nominating
your skin pigmentation
and your genitals that's what i'm
nominating because that's what i'm
making this decision based on
seems pretty insulting to me also sounds
pretty dehumanizing actually
all right number two um the irs is
planning to delay so this is a
good news i guess the delay the tax
deadline to may 50
actually i think may 17th they're
delaying it too um
so usually obviously april 15th tonight
you got an extra month
which is nice but my thing is they
should delay it
until never that's what it should be it
should be delayed until until never
there she really shouldn't be any income
tax at all
but especially right now if you're
worried about helping americans who've
been affected by the pandemic if you
want them to have more money in their
pockets
so they can go out and put it into the
economy and that's what you would do
but what does it tell you as i brought
up before
what does it tell you that through the
last year
republicans and democrats all of our
politicians
coming up with ideas of how can we
stimulate the economy how can we help
people
get through this and all that nobody
even
really suggested suspending the income
tax completely
for a year or two that wasn't even put
on the table for consideration
instead we're gonna spend trillions of
dollars to send money out to people
rather than simply
letting them keep their own money now
you might point out that suspending the
income tax isn't going to help people
who lost their jobs
because they don't have an income which
yeah that's true
but as we know the stimulus checks
already are going to a lot of people who
didn't lose their jobs
that's what i would if it were me that
that's that's what i would go with let
people keep their own money rather than
giving people money
first thing our first step default
position should be let people keep their
own money
number three we played the clip a couple
days ago of don lemon on the view
saying that god doesn't judge people and
there was more to that interview i think
this is the same interview at least
it's just gone viral now and um
gone viral for all the wrong reasons we
have a little bit more theological
insight
from don lemon that is almost as good as
the god doesn't judge people bit
let's listen to that and we also have to
start uh being realistic about god
and the bible and if you are a person of
faith in this country
and we know america is built on faith
and religious freedom
then we have to i think a good way of
starting
is to present the true identity of jesus
and that is as a black or a brown person
rather than someone who looks like a
white hippie from uh sweden or norway
and i think we should start with a true
depiction of what jesus looked like and
put that in your home
either a black jesus or brown jesus
because we knew jesus looked more like a
muslim or someone who was dark
rather than someone who is blonde uh a
blonde looking carpenter
and then when your children ask you who
is this this is jesus
jesus was middle eastern bethlehem was
not in stock
in sweden and so jesus does not look
like the
um popular depiction that we have in our
churches
uh and in our homes and that we see all
over the media and i think
that is a good place to start and that
is a good place that your kids
will ask questions and then you can go
from there and then we can
then we can come to a true reality about
what america really is okay oh bethlehem
isn't in sweden i had no idea
wow don lemon thanks first i'm hearing
that
now a few problems here number one
who cares what this person thinks
like why are we getting parenting advice
from him
why are we bringing him in to give
advice to parents or to give advice to
christians
on the best way to observe their faith
what kind of religious
icons they should have in their home
you know i'm not really sure i want
anyone's advice on that but why don
lemon of all people he is among the last
that i would go to for advice on that
uh another big problem is that he says
jesus would have looked muslim well
kind of an issue here islam didn't exist
2 000 years ago when jesus was
physically walking the earth
there was no such thing as muslim people
so that's a problem
yeah you know what he looked like he
looked like a jew because he was he
looked like a middle eastern jew which
is what he was
but don lemon goes with he looked muslim
a religion that didn't exist and
wouldn't exist for another 600 years
instead of just saying jesus was a
middle eastern jew
which by the way we all know that i love
how the
the left because they they don't know
they don't understand anything about
uh about religious people you know
except for their own
their own religious cult of leftism they
get that they understand their own but
they don't understand
christians and so they they always think
that they're blowing our minds
by saying hey did you know that jesus
wasn't white
what he wasn't this whole time i thought
yeah we're well aware of that not
troubled by it at all
now and the thing is the majority of
christians on earth
also are not white
you know christianity is not even close
to an exclusively white religion never
has been
that doesn't trouble us we're well aware
of that no it's you who doesn't appear
to be aware of that
that's something you need to remind
yourself
christianity is not uh white supremacy
that's what
that's a reminder you need we we know
that
in fact many of the most persecuted and
oppressed people across the globe
are non-white christians
because they are christians in
africa parts of asia
middle east north korea
yeah where they're sent to concentration
camps
and for the most part not white is where
they live
and these are among the most oppressed
and persecuted people on the globe
again a reminder that someone like don
lemon needs not us
we know that all right number four ron
desantis continues to be the best
elected republican in the country
and i think at this point he's just kind
of spiking the football um
or or lapping the field whatever sports
metaphor you want
hitting home runs dunking the ball uh
anyway and it's a low bar i admit to be
the best elected republican in the
in the country but even so here's what
he announced yesterday let's listen
florida civics curriculum will
incorporate foundational concepts
with the best materials and it will
expressly exclude
unsanctioned narratives like critical
race theory and other
unsubstantiated theories
[Applause]
let me be clear there's no room in our
classrooms for things
like critical race theory teaching kids
to hate their country and to hate each
other
is not worth one red cent of taxpayer
money
so we will invest in actual solid true
curriculum
and we will be a leader in the
development and in implementation
of a world-class civics education yeah
um
obviously exactly what needs to happen
this shouldn't even need to be a
discussion
clearly critical race theory does not
belong in the classroom
if you want to pick up books on that
subject yourself and indoctrinate
yourself you're more than
uh you're more than free to do so and if
you want to
elect a class on a subject like that in
in
college and you want to you want to send
yourself into bankruptcy you want to
take on all that debt to be
indoctrinated into
that have at it but it shouldn't be
in grade school where our kids cannot
choose it
are totally susceptible to it
you know don't don't have the
psychological equipment yet
to understand that they're being
indoctrinated and to separate fact from
fiction
and narrative from reality and so it
doesn't belong in the classroom
the only thing i would add to that is um
if we're if we're if we're talking about
theories that need to be taken out of
the classroom
critical race theory also gender theory
does not belong in the classroom those
two theories don't belong in the
classroom
really any anytime something has theory
attached to it
doesn't mean we don't teach it i mean
they're they're obviously theories that
we
that we do need to teach um but that's
something you gotta look at
a theory okay that that's gonna that's
gonna that should attract extra scrutiny
and maybe we could just sum it up this
way if it's not a valid
scientific theory
like the theory of gravity let's say if
it's not a valid scientific theory
then it doesn't belong in the classroom
scientific theories are systems to
explain
what we observe in the natural world so
they're very valuable in the scientific
context
but leftist theories these these systems
to explain
what we observe culturally and in
society those don't belong
all right number five from the daily
wire it says a gofundme set up to help
harry and megan to pay off the 14
million dollar mortgage
in their california home has folded
after less than a week
an alleged harry and megan megafan set
up the fund after hearing of the
couple's financial troubles in their
interview with oprah winfrey
memorably harry who has a trust fund
from his mother was worth millions
and was previously previously supported
by a generous grant from his father
complained that he and megan had to find
paying jobs in order to afford
private security and their modest home
they complained that they'd been uh cut
off financially
so then this gofundme was set up by a
generous benefactor or
or you know want to be benefactor
anastasia hansen
set up the gofundme account um and she
she explained when she set it up when
they came to the usa they were without
jobs and with limited funds
they've stated and they've had a very
rough time so this fundraiser is a way
to give help compassion and love
by paying their home loan in full where
two million supporters to donate just
five dollars each
the goal is met and the loan can be paid
off
now on top of that you can have the
peace of mind of knowing that you help
these multi-millionaires pay for their
mansion you know and you you can't put a
price tag on that
anyway the uh gofundme raised a total of
a hundred and ten dollars
which is a hundred 110 too much
and it raises a lot of questions about
the psychology of the people who
donated to this or set it up and it also
goes back to the question of why
is this deadbeat loser prince harry
depending on his parents
you're in your 30s and saying your my
parents have cut me off financially
of course they have yes
even if you weren't rich in your 30s you
ought to be cut off financially
time to time to leave the nest and fly
on your own baby bird
and if you can't then you'll splat on
the pavement and uh such is life
all right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments um
let's see preston wade says matt is the
peak of stereotypical fathers
i'll i'll take it i don't know exactly
what you mean by that but i'll take it
and
i even though i don't know what you mean
it's probably true
rachel says matt would probably be
horrified to learn that my bunny
sleeps in my bed with me at night
so you have essentially what is a large
rodent
maybe not technically sleeping in your
bed with you
yeah i am pretty horrified by that but
in fairness i'm i'm no
more horrified than i am by the people
that have
their dog sleeping in bed with them as i
already established
dogs don't belong in the home they
belong outside animals in general
you know there should be no species
aside from the human species
inside the home homes are for or for
humans
so we we invented homes animals lived
for millions of years without homes
without at least without um without
constructed dwellings like what we have
four walls and a ceiling
they did just fine so
and if if they can if they can't survive
without it then again that's
nature taking its course um abby runyon
says matt have you ever been to kansas
city missouri
i swear i saw you years ago at a barnes
noble here in kansas city
i even followed you around for a while
because i was seriously convinced
it was you and i've been a fan since
your early blog days
if it was you that's awesome if not
shame on you for not visiting one of the
greatest cities in the world
uh abby that was not me you were
following around
some poor random guy with a beard
probably scaring this guy half to death
and you're obviously banned from the
show but thank you for
being a fan until this moment when you
are now banned
um and finally jareth says i think matt
walsh is unfairly maligning my culture
in australia we abbreviate nearly
everything
sometimes even other abbreviations yeah
i did i did hear this a lot
when i complained yesterday about
grown-ups putting an e sound at the end
of word
abbreviating words with an e sound comfy
veggie
uh it's stimmy that's the latest i heard
from a lot of people in australia saying
that that's part of their culture
but i mean australia is also
a place australia is uh
is in many ways a horrifying nightmarish
land of man-eating spiders and so forth
that crawl from the ceilings in your
home so i
you know it's i'm not going to take that
as our example that we should emulate so
that doesn't
that does not at all come close to
justifying it and it does not take a lot
of effort
whatever the full word is stimulus
how long does take out a stopwatch how
long does does it take you to say the
word stimulus
now compare it to stimmy almost the same
amount of time
have some dignity some self-respect and
i want to tell you about our friends at
rock otto you know as the weather is
warming up people are emerging
outside out into society again in more
ways than one
you don't want to waste time at auto
parts stores if you have any problem
with a car or you need you need auto
parts for any reason
uh that's the last thing you want to do
is be it be inside auto parts store
and not only are you cooped up inside
but you're also
gonna be spent spending more than you
need to spend you're gonna be dealing
with a frustrating lack of selections
and lack of options
why do that when you can go to
rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
you know that they're going to do that
and they're going to be honest with you
because rockauto.com is a family
business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years you can go to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
best of all the prices at rockauto.com
are reliably low
and they're the same whether you're
professional or do-it-yourselfer doesn't
matter you're going to get the same
great price
the rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate you can
quickly find all the parts that
available for your car
truck and and all the specifications and
everything you need at rockauto.com so
go to rockauto.com right now and see all
the parts available for your car or
truck and remember of course to write
walsh in there how did you hear about us
box
so they know that we sent you also you
know there's a buzz in the air here at
daily wire candace owens filmed the
first episode of her new show yesterday
and it's all anyone in the office can
talk about this morning folks
you're going to love the show candace
premieres tomorrow and it will be unlike
any other daily wire show you've seen
before
and if you would like a sneak peek of
her new show and honestly why wouldn't
you
join candace owens in the rest of the
daily wire gang tonight for a special
edition of backstage we're going to
discuss candace's new show
as well as the big picture issues
affecting our nation namely
joe biden's terrifying accomplishments
if we can call it that
also cardi b's grammy performance uh
everything else that's going on
you can join candace and the rest of the
crew live at 7 p.m eastern 6 p.m
here in nashville at dailywire.com or
the daily wire youtube channel to be a
part of the conversation
don't forget candace premieres tomorrow
it'll be exclusive to daily wire members
and if you want to
watch the show go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code
candice now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so the interesting thing about the
debate surrounding biological males and
women's sports is that there really
isn't any debate at all you know a
debate involves
argument an exchange of ideas between
people of opposing sides on a particular
issue
and this requires each side to have some
sort of coherent point of view and for
them each to present that point of view
in a manner that might be intelligible
to their opponents
none of that is happening with respect
to this issue the side which favors
opening up female sports and locker
rooms to males
has not bothered to launch any coherent
defense of this change
or give any good reason for anyone to
agree with it other than to scream empty
buzzwords like bigot and transphobes at
those who fail to cooperate with them
carl sagan liked to say that
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
now it could just as well be said that
extraordinary policy proposals require
extraordinary
justifications in this case there is
both an extraordinary claim
that some males are really women and an
extraordinary proposal that biological
sex should not be considered as a factor
in who gets admitted into women's sports
yet there is nothing approaching
extraordinary evidence or extraordinary
justification
for these assertions there is not even
ordinary evidence in justification there
is nothing those who favor putting males
in female sports have not bothered to
defend their claim at all or to engage
with the
with the points raised by the other side
the points on the other side are
simple straightforward but also powerful
for example here's author abigail
schreier testifying before the senate
yesterday about the so-called equality
act
and raising a number of i think very
pertinent questions let's listen
if your daughter or granddaughter was
the top high school
tennis player in her state and then five
biological boys
suddenly decided at the age of 17 to
identify as female
should she drop overnight to number six
should she lose her college scholarship
to a male-bodied athlete
who would never have qualified on the
boys team
does that strike any member of this
committee as fair or just
if a woman in your state commits a crime
should she be put in a correctional
facility with biological males
some of whom are sex offenders some of
whom may have only begun
identifying as female weeks earlier
all of whom could easily overpower her
if a preschool has a policy that only
female teachers may accompany
little girls to the bathroom and your
daughter's male teacher suddenly
identifies as female
ought that teacher to have a legal
entitlement to accompany her
does that strike anyone in this room as
safe or sensible
those are good questions questions that
need to be answered by the people
proposing this stuff
but they won't answer them they have
again nothing to offer
so to illustrate my point let's turn to
a recent article in the allegedly
reputable publication scientific
american
the piece written by child psychiatrist
dr jack turbin
titled trans girls belong on girls
sports teams
claims that there is no scientific case
for excluding biological males from
female sports
now this is certainly extraordinary no
case
it's been thought for millennia that
males have biological advantages over
women
that give them the edge in sports combat
and other physical contests
jack turbine insists that there is no
scientific case not simply a weak case
but
no case at all to support this bias
he then spends several thousand words
explaining why except
he never does explain why the actual
article
itself doesn't prove or even really
attempt to prove
the opening thesis here's what it says
instead the article begins
with the lawsuit filed in federal court
by the family of three girls
cis girls as the author calls them in an
effort to make biological females seem
like but one possible type of girl one
variant
they're suing the connecticut
association of schools for allowing boys
to compete against girls in track and
field the author turbine
attempts to debunk the premise of the
lawsuit writing
quote after the connecticut lawsuit was
filed by the cisgender girls families
one of those girls beat one of the
transgender girls named in the lawsuit
in a connecticut state championship it
turns out that when transgender girls
play on girls sports teams
cisgender girls can win in fact the vast
majority of female athletes are
cisgender
as are the vast majority of winners
there's no epidemic of transgender girls
dominating female sports attempts to
force transgender girls to play on the
boys team
are unconscionable attacks on already
marginalized transgender children
and they don't address a real problem
they're unscientific and they would
cause serious mental health damage to
both cisgender and transgender youth
now obviously the fact that some girls
can beat
some guys in some sports sometimes does
not at all prove that boys don't have an
inherent advantage
i'm sure there are some blind people who
can beat some
seeing people in a game of darts but no
sane person would suggest that sight is
not an advantage
in a contest like that the point with
respect to those male athletes running
running track in connecticut is that
they were winning gold silver and bronze
medals with times that would not have
qualified them to step onto the track
against the men against the men against
their fellow males they were subpar
runners
12th 13th 14th 15th place or worse
against the women they were top
competitors that's the advantage
and this scientific article doesn't so
much as try to deal with that fact
it just ignores the fact as it ignores
every other fact
later on it says quote the notion of
transgender girls having an
unfair advantage comes from the idea
that testosterone causes physical
changes such as an increase in muscle
mass
but transgender girls are not the only
girls with high testosterone levels
an estimated 10 of women have polycystic
ovarian syndrome
which results in elevated testosterone
levels they are not banned from female
sports
transgender girls on puberty blockers on
the other hand have negligible
testosterone levels
yet these state bills would force them
to play with the boys
plus the atlantic the athletic advantage
conferred by the testosterone is
equivocal
as ke as uh katrina karkasi
a senior visiting fellow an expert on
testosterone and bioethics at yale
university explains
studies of testosterone levels and
athletics do not show any clear
consistent relationship between
testosterone and athletic performance
sometimes testosterone is associated
with better performance but other
studies show weak links or no links
and yet others show testosterone is
associated with worse performance
the bill's premise lacks scientific
validity
okay now even if i were to simply accept
this
ridiculous claim the testosterone
doesn't give you an advantage or even
it's a disadvantage
in a physical sport and even if i were
to pretend that there's some relevance
to the minority of women with an ovarian
condition
that gives them more of the hormone even
if i were to accept all of that
and even if i were to pretend again for
the sake of this argument which he wants
us to pretend
that all of the male athletes competing
against women
are on puberty blockers which is not
true
well let's say let's just give him all
of that
it still would not come close to proving
the case that men have no physical
advantage over women in sports
testosterone is but one factor
one as an article in live science in
2017 noted an article that
would probably not be published today
men along with having up to 20 times
more testosterone than women
also have greater muscle mass large
larger fast twitch muscle fibers
larger lungs larger hearts longer legs
smaller waists
less body fat and this is but a partial
list
all of these physical factors give men a
distinct profound
significant physical advantage this is
why all of the fastest and strongest
people in the world are men this is why
there is no state in the union where the
top female runners have on average
faster times than the top male runners
this is why a decent male high school
basketball player could walk into the
wnba
and dominate without having to try that
hard
it all comes back to physiology and this
article which is supposed to
be providing a thorough scientific case
for allowing males and women sports
does not deal with any of these
physiological factors
those two paragraphs that i read are the
extent of the scientific case presented
from there
his argument revolves solely around the
feelings of trans athletes claiming that
it will be emotionally painful for some
men
if they're not allowed to compete
against women but this is negated by the
fact that it's emotionally painful for
women to have their privacy and athletic
opportunities stolen by men
at a minimum we have an emotional wash
right a stalemate
with both sides making emotional claims
now in reality the emotions of the men
are far outweighed by the women both
because there are a lot more women
affected
and because the emotional demands of the
men are far more unreasonable than that
of the women
but even if we pretend again that it's
an even emotional match
still we are left having to fall back on
the scientific argument
as far as that goes as we've seen the
other side really has no scientific
argument
at all which doesn't stop them from
publishing in something called
scientific american and so
that's why the author of this article is
cancelled
and anyone who reads that article or or
at least reads the headline which is
what most people will do and what
they're counting on you doing
and is simply persuaded that well the
article says it in the headline it's in
something called scientific american now
they must have a scientific case
anyone dumb enough to do that and i fear
there are millions of them
also canceled and we'll leave it there
for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel voldowsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. a prominent
lobbyist can't tell the senate how many
sexes there are joe biden forgets what
he said a few months ago
and america can't make sense of a tragic
shooting check it out on the michael
knowles show